bella tutti ragazzi e bentornati su
harry io sono fa vj eravamo rimasti che
abbiamo spento un generatore e quella
fare lì mi stava prendendo scusate
secondo se inizio già muovermi senza
avere introdotto decentemente ma quel
c'è un mostro per chi non avesse visto
primi episodi comunque se lo guardi se
non ci capisce niente c'è un mostro che
mi segue che sarebbe questo cazzo come
loro ok forse riesco ad aggirare
perfetto c'è sta a fare qui che mi segue
io devo riuscire a fare qualcosa senza
che lui vi prenda ovviamente
vado di qua e quindi scusate se mi muovo
alla veloce ma devo riuscire ad evitarlo
quindi non posso star fermo abbiamo
spento un generatore devo spegnere
l'altro ok secondo tornati qui non so
come sono tornato qua ragazzi però non è
un buon segno perché vuol dire che ci
può tornare pure lui
ok ok a fare qua io credo che grande
grande e stupido però meno ma è brutto
quanto è stupido corri corri corri corri
corri corri corri dove siamo qui noi
siamo siamo di nuovo l'inizio però qua
non ci devo venire
ok allora devo raggirarli in qualche
modo ci prova devono devo tornare
davvero prima quindi devo farlo farlo
venire qui perfetto
vieni a sfidare lo spray al peperoncino
ok ragazzi non mi ricordo dove il bagno
siamo nel bagno perfetto da dentro
[ __ ] [ __ ] benissimo allora devo
riuscire a trovare uscita l'ho già
trovata
ok devo riuscire ad arrivare all'altro
generatore prima possibile perchè se no
cosa fare mi prende pazienza l'avete
capito fin qua problema che non ho la
più pallida idea di dove possa essere
questo è il vero unico problema allora
di qua ci sono già stato però era noto
sinistra andiamo a destra che c'era un
altro mostro tra tra l'altro cos'è
questo
un deposito è già qualcosa o forse l'ho
trovato forse non cos'è g2 che il card
acquired ok ho trovato un'altra chiave
ragazzi quell'affare non mi sta più
seguendo quindi meglio così ragazzi non
è un bambino questo ma è un gatto come
nello scorso episodio
qua si possa dire sì si può salire uomo
fantastico mi sembrano non mi piglia
ok sta arrivando forse non ci arriva
spero di no potere dello spray fossero
da ok
direi che funziona si assaggia
assaggiano che buono stato
questo è il sapore della sconfitta
stronzo non è che sarà anche lui adesso
no non sale non ce la fa meno ma ok ok
invece ce la fa ok ce la sta facendo
muoviamoci come come faccio il ricordo
per riuscire a trovare un'altra uscita
prima che lui mi raggiunga questo è
sicuro
dio che brutto che mamma mia
va beh cos'è starò un gatto un gatto un
gatto ho trovato un gatto morto ragazzi
non chiedetemi a cosa serve ma qualcosa
serve per questo gioco si raccolgono i
gatti morti c'è ci sono giochi dove si
raccolgono pagine nascoste quasi non si
raccolgono i gatti morti tutto un perché
non so che cosa ci sono venuto a fare
qui sopra ma devo fucile prima possibile
quindi me la dà a gambe mi seguirà di
sicuro quindi devo fare in fretta via
suor i cori coricò ricordi mi segue già
ok è rimasto incastrato per un po spero
che questo mi abbia fatto guadagnare a
me un po di tempo ragazzi perché non ho
idea di dove andare
ho sbagliato strada dove andare di qua
bene bene bene bene bene qua prima mi
avevi incagliato l'ultimo episodio
perché questa porta è chiusa adesso
aperta
era la chiave di prima perfetto ragazzi
due su tre gli spenti
ne manca uno che presumo sia l'ultima
porta qui a destra questa qui
che è chiusa devo trovare prima la
chiave perfetto mi manca una chiave
ragazzi non so dove trovarla però il
problema è questo
speriamo non mi spunti adesso perché ce
l'avrei nel ca pranzi perfetto non mi ha
ascoltato anni avanti questa porta non
si apre lì come ragazzi di come cielo
arrivato non mi ricordo più
forse ho capito allora devo entrare in
questo tour
qui perfetto andiamo ragazzi c'è una
porta in fondo però l'ultima volta mi
pare che non si era aperta adesso non mi
ricordo se ho trovato delle chiavi che
potessero aprirla però l'ultima volta ma
si era aperta allora di qua
innanzitutto non ci sono ancora andato
quindi darei un occhiata prima fu i
ragazzi poi alla porta perfetto
dimostrino l'occhiata la porta che non
si apre perfetto allora qua ci sono già
stato qui non so che cosa c'è sinistra a
destra né a sinistra madonna immenso
stupore ragazzi e un posto enorme se non
potrò mai controllato tutto siamo finiti
cosa laboratorio ok perfetto va o che
bello ha perso un braccio oddio non si
gioca al piccolo chimico
se non sai come ad operare gli strumenti
perché l'hai fatto
vabbè altri bambini che piangono che
normalmente in questo gioco sono gatti
però vabbè sangue non promette bene
cos'è sta roba ragazzi mi sembra di
essere passato a giocare a dead space
non trovo l'ultima chiave però l'ultima
chiave dovrebbe essere nascosta da
qualche parte ma non la trovo che cazzo
essa è lui a e sottovuoto fantastico mio
amicone in scatola praticamente è come
ha fatto uscire
quello che mi sta seguendo poteva
starsene lì che stava anche al calduccio
scommetto che l'acqua calda vabbè dovuto
alla per i [ __ ] a me invece di
starsene di tranquillo
ok ragazzi finora non ho trovato nessuna
chiave assi così sono i così propri essa
porta quando spento tutti i generatori
st stanza non serve assolutamente una
minchia solo farmi capire che quel sexy
boy è scappato da uno di si cosi vabbè
fin qui cielo arrivato continua sentire
il suo verso tra virgolette tra l'altro
però lui non lo vedo ancora meno male
trovata l'ho trovata ragazzo trovato ad
essa chiave ok devo tornare indietro non
promette bene sto suono probabilmente
non ero io non mi risulta di essere così
pesante la fareste rumore c'è ma sono
tornate loro prima ora che cazzo serve a
raggirare tipo nel caso si facesse vivo
ma non c'è non devo morire ragazzi
soprattutto non voglia di vederlo o che
era che dobbiamo tornare alla porta
numero 3 chi si ricorda dove era mi fa
un favore melodika anch'esso già
registrato il video perché io non me lo
ricordo allora
la porta abbiamo detto che non si apre
ok devo andare
ma qui c'era qualcosa perché io non ho
visto niente qui a quasimodo stiamo
tornando indietro che perfetto allora
devo fare tipo mirror's edge vai a james
bond
devo arrivare ragazze la porta numero 3
che sta non mi ricordo dove però andiamo
a tentoni prima o poi la troviamo anzi
più o meno un'idea ce l'ho però
precisamente non me lo ricordo allora
qua siamo in troppi tornati di nuovo nel
posto dove posso trovare il mio
amatissimo amico questa è la porta
perfetto l'ho trovata ragazzi ultimo
generatore
ok e sono tre adesso la porta si è
aperta perfetto un altro corridoio
uguale non potevo aspettarmi di meglio
da dove sono arrivati ragazzi di qua
sono tutti uguali e strade
bene non c'è chi traccia del mio
amichetto saranno ok
non mi ricordo più ragazzi c'è una
memoria veramente di merda un criceto si
ricordati di me ah ecco ok del mio amico
lì non c'è più traccia
fortunatamente quindi magari è andato
già avanti e mi anticipa lui perché è
possibile infatti la mia teoria forse e
giusta che è trovare che bordello ma che
ragazzi ma che cos'è sto bordello mi
esplodono le cuffie bene qua c'è
tastiera lifeguard cosa ho fatto
oddio non sa dove andare
ok infilati dov'è il buco qui mamma mia
ragazzi mamma mia l'ho scampata bella
ma quanti sono volete pelle lo spray
ok basta era eccessiva sa cosa mi
sembrava giusto farla sento veramente
mammamia le cuffie mi stanno esplodendo
spero che non lo sentite anche voi così
tanto abbasserò volume penso
nell'edificio
ok c'è qualcosa che non mi piace però va
beh devo tuffarmi qui bene nata a chiave
ragazzi sembra mio telecomando c'è
veramente più non ha non ha nulla di
chiave sta roba
ok mi sono andato una sportellata in
faccia fantastico destra a sinistra dove
sono ragazzi sto posto è nuovo ma ci
sono già stato perché questa era la
porta chiusa
e allora devo tornare oggi hanno
sfondato i cancelli merda
devo tornare all'inizio ragazzi devo
riuscire a tornare sano e salvo
all'inizio ci sono le frecce a terra
raga che spero indicano ci sono le
frecce a terra almeno che spero
indichino la strada perché sennò non non
ci saprei tornare perfetto mi son dato
un'altra sportellate in faccia ragazzi
mi starà odiando il personaggio visto
gioco
vabbè cha cha cha abbiamo fatto forse
exit d'or unlock ce l'ho fatta
devono riuscire ad entrare nella porta
perfetto vai uscita
che bello e tutto molto più grave di
fenomeni finalmente un ambiente diverso
come no
siamo stiamo veramente uscendo non ci
posso credere ieri due skype e tintura
like her è ok adesso tu creatore del
gioco ci sediamo assieme io e te seduti
tranquilli ci beviamo un tè e mi spieghi
tranquillamente come cazzo è venuto in
mente di mettere un personaggio nelle
fogne
però questi sono dettagli e domande che
non avranno mai risposta comunque solo
che il gameplay vi sia piaciuto
ovviamente durava poco videogame
vi lascio al link in descrizione come al
solito per il download come faccio
sempre
niente se vi è piaciuto video consente a
quelli siti iscrivetevi lasciate mi
piace sulla pagina facebook che trovate
sempre in descrizione è anche al video
se vi è piaciuto e noi ci vediamo
prossimo video bei ragazzi
[Musica]
paniz sophie ok che cazzo
ma